when the president suggested withholding
funds from sanctuary cities in in order
to try and get them to obey then or
there's outrage in the usual quarters
but guess what now you have Democrat
governors pulling the exactly the same
trick saying they're going to withhold
funds from local areas that don't
enforce their shutdowns and they're
doing this even as we're seeing the
incredible cost for example just one
part of it which is the closure of
schools in terms of children's mental
health and yet these governors are
threatening to withhold funds and yet
there's not a peep from the same people
that were complaining when Donald Trump
was threatening the same thing the worst
of it all is listen to the way some of
them talk just listen to this language
from Pennsylvania Governor Tom wolf
these folks are choosing to desert in
the face of the enemy to those
politicians who decide to cave in to
this coronavirus they need to understand
the consequences of their cowardly act
what an odious little Tim pot tyrant he
is I couldn't believe it when I heard
that Charlie your response I mean it's
unbelievable I mean you have these
governors now that are so out of touch
with the citizens they actually actually
represent if the left did not have
double standards they wouldn't have
standards at all they are crying foul
and the president wants to actually
enforce immigration policy through the
direction of federal funds and then when
they actually want to then enforce their
own out-of-touch ruling-class proposals
they use the very same taxes that
tactics that they accused the president
of so now you're seeing a tale of two
Americas
you see these governors like Tom wolf
and you see other governors like Andrew
Cuomo and Gavin Newsom that just seem to
keep on digging in to these now failed
unscientific decisions and proposals
that their citizens are starting to
resist and part of what being a populist
does Steve we're you and I have really
tried to articulate the last couple
years is listening to the people the
people are upset they want their Liberty
back they want their freedom back it is
essential more than ever
and a big part of that agenda Katie
which I know we've talked about this
it's so important is the
decentralization of power and you're
seeing with these governor
there they're not in for example in
Pennsylvania saying no you can't even if
your county might be completely
different to account the more urban area
you can't go your own way that is just
the opposite of what our Constitution
was all about which is the
decentralization of power
yeah and I'm in CHEM in Florida right
now and have been since the virus broke
out Florida's handling this very
differently the governor of Florida has
left it up to the individual counties
some counties sparsely populated have
had absolutely very little problem
they've had very few cases they've had
very few deaths other parts of Florida
have had very high concentrations so
he's left it up to the to the counties
the counties in many cases have left it
out to the mayors why because the people
closest to the ground who know their
populations they know their communities
they know which communities have a
problem which communities don't and as
long as everybody's following the common
sense things like social distancing wash
your hands etc and then it really should
be left up to the smallest group of
society to figure out and I want to
contrast this to China China is the
ultimate expression of authoritarian big
government right and it's a total
surveillance state there require even
China surveillance state that it is is
having separate regulations whether
you're in Wuhan or whether you're in
Beijing or whether you're in Shanghai so
even the Communist Chinese even the most
authoritarian nation in the world
isn't quite as authoritarian of some of
the government Democrat governors in the
United States and then disa I mean what
about the language there from Tom Wolfe
I mean I just staggering to insult
people who were just trying to do the
right thing and and earn a living there
I couldn't believe that language well
and I think the biggest challenge too is
a lot of the elected officials aren't
making any sense and quite honestly
we're being governed by morons and if
you look at the city of Boston the mayor
there it's true though the mayor they
are delayed reopening because of a
serological study that showed that you
know 90% of the city the citizens in the
city have not contracted coronavirus
they think only 10% has so he's not
going to reopen but the reason they
haven't is because the city's been
closed
so how are they gonna get you know
higher levels with the city shut down so
it just defies logic it makes no sense
and then you've got governor como saying
that no one should be prosecuted for
nursing home deaths
well of course he holds that theory it
was his mandate in his administration's
mandate that sent Kovac patients into
the nursing homes and then infected
other people and unfortunately so many
people have died because of that failed
policy and lastly we've had so many
officials tell us that testing is the
key to reopening well como was
complaining the other day that one third
of the facility these the testing
capabilities are not being utilized
because none of people are showing up so
the biggest challenge here is we have
people that make no sense they're not
doing it according to the data and so I
think that's why so many people are
really distrusting their leaders right
now mm-hmm okay so that you've just
reminded me of something I've been
wanting to do on the show for a long
time I can't quite do I'm going to do it
now and waste time but it's it's a
sticker yeah Bend on that Bend Domenech
gave me a founder of the Federalist it's
absolutely brilliant and only I need a
visual prop for it so that's a tease for
a upcoming show quick last word on the
point I made just the beginning of that
Charlie on schools
I mean why aren't schools being reopened
you can't going to get the economy open
if parents can't go to work that's
exactly right a turning point USA we
represent over 2000 college and high
schools across the country and young
people have been shown through data to
not be as at risk as other parts of the
population yet their proms have been
canceled commencement I've been canceled
final point Steve is without the schools
that will never reopen the Catholic
schools on the eastern seaboard in New
Jersey the archdiocese says dozens of
these Catholic schools will never reopen
because they'll go bankrupt and families
can't afford the tuition anymore
so it's not like you can just turn the
switch back on and all of a sudden you
can go back to these schools we once
knew and loved and grew up in there will
be an incalculable cost if we continue
these draconian lockdowns now you go
exactly right